Apple's Vision Pro headset is here and
apparently it's the most advanced
personal electronics device ever so in
this video I'm going to answer the
question of if that statement is true
and everyone should try to get one or if
it's just an overpriced thirty five
hundred dollar gimmick well for starters
it looks absolutely incredible from
every angle especially the fabric which
looks super comfy and soft as well as
the speaker enclosures the way the
charger magnetically holds on and of
course the curved black glass and the
external face display now I've got to
say that yes the memes were real and you
can actually see people's eyes through
the headset which is a little bit
awkward and weird but it's actually more
useful than you think which I'll get
into in just a minute as for the price
it's extremely expensive and it seems
like apple is positioning this product
for only the most wealthy people because
that price will make even the rich
squirm a bit so it's really meant for
early adopters yes it's jam-packed with
state-of-the-art sensors and displays
with up to 23 million pixels which seems
completely unreal but it's actually
going to give you a real life experience
compared to other VR headsets which you
can clearly see the shape of pixels
everywhere and that ruins the realistic
feel with Apple's headset they're able
to use the external cameras to feed your
surrounding views into the internal
displays with basically no latency and
since the pixels are so tiny it'll look
like you're viewing your room with your
own eyes which is insane the craziest
part is that it has a ton of sensors to
track your eyes to know exactly where
you are looking which is part of how you
control it no controllers needed at all
since you simply look around tap and
move your fingers and use your voice the
even crazier thing was when they said
you can look at a text field and
instantly start talking and it'll start
typing in without having to say Siri or
anything else so yes the tech and
software that they packed into this
thing is absolutely insane but for three
thousand five hundred dollars man is
that a stretch for even the highest
income earners out there but what if
it's so good that it's worth saving as
much cash as you possibly can to buy
this thing early next year instead of
some other Apple product upgrades like a
new iPhone or a new Mac but anyway Apple
showed off a ton of features so I want
to get into the ones that I think are
pretty gimmicky and the ones that most
people will actually use and enjoy on a
daily basis yes using it on an airplane
to completely block out your
surroundings sounds really cool but
there are a couple of problems with this
idea first of all you've got to have
enough guts to put a huge device advice
on your face in front of everybody on
your plane it's really going to take a
few years before this gets normalized
but even if you've got the guts we have
the problem of the speakers Apple said
that they can trick your brain into
thinking that the spatial sound is
coming from your ambient environment and
that's because nothing goes over your
ears so if you're using the headset
everyone around you is going to hear
what's going on so you absolutely must
connect airpods when you're on an
airplane and that could ruin that
ambient feel now there are some other
things that I think will be gimmicks but
first I want to get into the things that
I think will actually be very cool and
useful on a daily basis first up we have
watching movies and shows because it's
gonna make it so much more immersive you
basically get a huge projector screen in
front of you instantly with just the
headset on the only problem is that this
experience is only for one person with
which is you to watch movies or shows
with anybody else in your house or
family you have to ditch the headset and
that immersive experience but the really
cool and unique thing is watching 3D
movies like Avatar 2 which you could
usually only watch in the theaters this
is going to be the only device out there
that you could do with Standalone at
home on your couch another big one that
I'm really excited for is using this
with a Mac by just looking at the
display and bringing it up in front of
you you're going to be able to replace
an HDR monitor like the six thousand
dollar Pro display xdr from Apple
imagine just buying a small 13-inch
MacBook Air and then connecting that to
the headset to get a huge display to use
right in front of your face that is one
way it actually makes sense to buy the
headset instead of a crazy expensive
display now another awesome feature that
Apple added which I'm very thankful
before is the fine tuning of immersivity
using the crown this is awesome because
you can use your apps and your Mac and
everything else in your room while also
being able to see the people in your
room and what's going on at all times
and the fact that the speakers don't
cover your ears means that you can
always hear your surroundings with no
problems at all people can even see your
eyes using Apple's incredibly good
Avatar that you create during the setup
process so it looks just like you this
feature is essentially called eyesight
and the crazy thing is that you'll be
able to make direct eye contact with
people in your room and when you're
fully immersed into an app it'll cover
up your eyes to tell people that you
can't see them this feature alone solves
a bunch of the problems that people
thought would happen so essentially
you're free to multitask with a bunch of
apps at once while also talking to your
family members so you never have to take
off the headset which you can't do on
any other VR headset out there now
another big feature is working in an
office environment that communication
feature with others in your room can
translate perfectly to a work
environment like what I do on a daily
basis researching and writing scripts on
my work desktop Mac instead of having to
get a super nice quality 5K a display
like a 5k iMac I can simply use a small
Mac Mini or a small MacBook and then get
a huge display right in front of my face
and even add more displays on the side
for like Google Drives docs for writing
or multiple research Windows all huge in
front of my face and at the same time I
can hear and see my co-workers on the
side and check out what's going on on
their actual Mac displays all with the
headset on and I could actually see
myself using the Vision Pro headset in
this way another one is remote work or
travel let's say you're working in a
hotel you don't have to bring a huge
display or multiple displays just bring
a small 13-inch MacBook and make the
screen massive for your work and then
also gaming would be awesome because you
get a huge display so for something like
FPS Shooters you can see everything up
close instead of just something small on
your iPhone or on your iPad that is a
huge deal being able to connect a PS4
controller and playing any of the Apple
arcade games or hopefully more coming
soon and now let's get into some of the
gimmicks that Apple showed off first of
all viewing your photos and videos I
feel like that's a gimmick because most
people are going to continue to just use
their iPhone to look at photos same
thing for recording video using the
headset I can't imagine anybody
deliberately bringing their Vision Pro
headset to take photos or videos the
quickest way is to just grab your iPhone
out of your pocket and take a photo sure
they have the cool 3D recording feature
but you can only watch it using the
headset at least for now another one is
just browsing the web most of the time
when you need to browse or look
something up you just grab your phone to
do a quick bit of research with the
headset you'd need to dedicate time to
put it on and browse the web search
around everywhere so I can't really see
myself using that except for when it's a
work environment and I'm doing research
another one they showed off is FaceTime
I can't imagine anybody putting this
thing on to do FaceTime since it'll show
your avatar which could be a bit weird
instead of seeing your actual face and
all of your surroundings when my wife
uses FaceTime it's because she wants the
kids to see their grandparents and them
to see the kids not for them to Simply
see her Avatar alone that's definitely a
gimmick so with all that said do I think
this thing is a gimmick or is it
actually useful in the real world well
honestly headset simply upgrades the
Xperia
experience other devices it if you enjoy
watching movies on your TV or laptop The
Vision Pro will upgrade the experience
and make it more immersive if you're
already playing games on your iPhone or
iPad you'll get a big screen experience
with the headset the problem with the
headset is that game support will be
very limited at launch so if your game
isn't on the headset you will not be
gaming on it you'll just grab your phone
or computer even if you already bought
the headset and most people doing work
on their MacBooks are already happy
doing it this way so I don't think the
headset will really change that and make
people want to buy it for that I
honestly think the people buying this
will be those who have a bunch of extra
money lying around and they want to
experience the future with the awesome
immersive new reality in front of their
eyes the only scenario I can imagine
where it financially makes sense to buy
the reality Pro is when you're buying
this headset instead of an expensive
large display Max setup like buying this
instead of the produce display xdr in
that case you should definitely buy it
another one could be for stock day
traders who set up a bunch of displays
to track various stocks all at once the
reality Pro would ideally be able to
replace them all in this one device but
for everything else it's just for fun to
get an awesome immersive experience and
you might be better off waiting a couple
of years for developers to get their
apps fine-tuned for the headset you let
me know your thoughts on it down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
the video click the circle about to
subscribe for more WWDC content coming
soon thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
thank you